Gregg Gordon how many legal claims have
been filed with regard to asbestos in
this country do you know no one knows
which is one of the remarkable things
about this whole issue the the
dimensions of the asbestos problem which
is one of the real colossal tragedies of
the 20th century in America and now into
the 21st century are really not known
fully there are projections by public
health experts but before it's over a
half a million workers will be dead I
have these related illnesses very
briefly when what is asbestos and why
have there been so many lawsuits filed
asbestos is a naturally forming mineral
that when it flakes off or crumbles
produces microscopic fibers which one
they embed in your lungs can cause of
about three or four different
progressive lung illnesses the worst
being a rare cancer of the lining of the
lungs known as mesothelioma kills about
two to three thousand people a year and
it's it's not curable and the reason
there are so many lawsuits is that there
are so many sick people some some
projections call for more than two
million Americans to suffer from
asbestos related illnesses before this
is over in the next 50 years if it if it
can be reined in
totally what was asbestos or is asbestos
II used for industrially and how do
people get exposed to it
well asbestos is of course best known as
a fire retardant it was used in fire
retardant sprays inside buildings to
protect people in case there's a there's
a fire and it's used in brake pads in
cars it's used in horticultural products
because it well it wasn't
asbestos wasn't really used in the
horticultural products of vermiculite
that is mined at formed for mines in the
United States
it contains if
means of asbestos and this wasn't known
for a time and then it was thought by
some that it wasn't anything to worry
about but it turns out that it's also
claimed a very large toll of of
Americans with illnesses now okay what
has Congress done by the way we're
talking about asbestos legislation and
lawsuits if you'd like to dial in the
numbers are on the screen what has
Congress done with regard to asbestos
and the lawsuits here's the problem
there are now 67 American companies in
bankruptcy because of the huge number of
asbestos claims hundreds of thousands
have already been filed Johns Manville
which was the biggest producer of
asbestos products went bankrupt some
twenty years ago and it has alone
received twenty thousand claims which
I'm sorry has received six hundred
thousand claims and a large percentage
of those have since been settled but
originally they were gonna pay a hundred
cents on the dollar they're now paying a
nickel on the dollar so a lot of people
today are are sick and ending up with
very little compensation from the
companies that were culpable or that
were alleged to be culpable so now we
have bill been found culpable just
alleged to be essentially admitted
culpability it has a trust that pays out
to claimants based on certain medical
criteria that they must meet and there
are as I said 67 other companies that
are in bankruptcy and many many other
companies the the total number of
corporate defendants in asbestos
litigation is today about eighty four
hundred in the United States and again
the Congressional role Congress's role
has been to try to come up with some
kind of a massive settlement that will
resolve what is becoming a growing
problem and that is how to take care of
these people who are sick how to
compensate their survivors if asbestos
shortened their lives and there have
been attempts in Congress for a number
of years to try to come up with a global
settlement that might sort of mirror
that that that was achieved with the
tobacco industry
and and put into law this year there's a
great momentum to try to do something in
part I think because the business
community recognizes that they've got
the House the Senate and the White House
and that they might be able to get some
legislation through that will be a
little bit more sympathetic to business
than maybe a Democratic Congress might
have an adopted and and the problem is
that there's not really enough money or
there hasn't historically been enough
money to go around under any scenario to
take care of all these people and so
they're trying to come up with something
that will at least be more equitable
today you have lawsuits being resolved
in Mississippi for far larger amounts of
money compensation to victims than say
in Montana it's inequitable some people
happen to be victims of companies that
went into chapter 11 bankruptcy and they
get much less money in the end then then
a victim of say a General Motors or a
Ford that are still operating companies
and maybe it got exposed to too much
asbestos dust off brake pads why are we
talking about this today senator orrin
hatch the chairman of the Judiciary
Committee with some cooperation and and
and collaboration from from Senate
Democrats has been trying to forge a
compromise deal for months it's going on
for about four months now and today
senator hatch plans to formally
introduce draft legislation that would
maybe be the start at start of attempts
in Congress to mark up something that
would be acceptable to all parties the
problem is that the afl-cio which
essentially represents union workers is
very unhappy with what the senator is
finally putting
after all these talks why well the the
number that I didn't see a number in 111
page a bill that the senator has is and
he could he could have changed in the
last couple of days but the draft
measure that he circulated two days ago
did not have a global number in it that
I could find but I'm told that then it
would involve about a hundred and eight
billion dollars over 26 years
essentially but presumably the plan
would be to cover victims going back or
going on going forward for maybe 40 50
years labor says the number is too low
and it's chief concern is the
description of the other in the
standards for the the medical criteria
that that victims would have to meet to
be compensated what kind of rigor
rigorous testing would they have to go
through what kind of proof would they
have to make before they would be
covered and then there's there's a scale
for diseases ranging from what is known
as pleural disease which is a certain
amount of scarring on your own your lung
Melora of your lungs which is the outer
lining and this is what what causes the
breathing problems that these people
encounter or you could have it
asbestosis a much more serious
restrictive lung disease or lung cancer
or at the top in the worst case
mesothelioma but the disease I mentioned
a few minutes ago and the the afl-cio
doesn't feel there's enough money and
for these categories of these categories
okay let's get our callers involved here
first call up is from let's say our
first call up is from Detroit good
morning
Detroit you're on the air hear me all
right yes good morning all right I've
got a comment and a question
a real quick comment is I don't think
the American people understand just how
hard it is to litigate against a major
corporation I was involved in a lawsuit
for four years and finally things
aspiration everybody just settle for
pennies on the dollar and when you
contact your agencies your governmental
agency specifically the FCC you'll find
that there's no cops on the beat there's
nobody home these agencies have been
gutted my question for you sir is and I
see that you investigate these types of
things
have you ever investigated the
biological hazards other than other
neurotoxins especially electromagnetic
radiation that comes from Tyler's high
kilovolt transmission lines recently
there was a study finally came out by
the EPA about how this causes cancer and
how this is really a number one this is
a more serious cartridge end and and
asbestos and neural toxins and causes a
lot of diseases Kraig Gordon well I have
to say in a former job I worked for the
Detroit News and I actually did a four
part series on toxins in the workplace
other than asbestos and one thing I
would say about asbestos is the
dispenses is easier to litigate because
it leaves scarring on the lungs and and
it leaves asbestos fibers in the body if
you have exposure to something like say
cobalt dust or some of these chemicals
and solvents that are used in the auto
industry they leave your body and then
you have to turn around and try to prove
your exposure twenty or thirty years
before you got cancer and it's extremely
difficult as you say and in fact a lot
of the toxic tort bars they call the
lawyers who represent victims of various
toxins as dried up I haven't done any
work on electromagnetic fields but I
know if you just if you if you buy a
cell phone and you look at the brochure
that comes with your cell phone it says
we don't know whether or not it causes
cancer so proceed with that knowledge
there are many many substances in the
environment that people can be exposed
to there's very difficult to litigate I
agree Pensacola Florida good morning hey
how you doing good hi mr. Gordon I'd
like to know who's really in control of
this
taking care of people that have been
exposed to asbestos because I tell you I
spent 20 years in the Navy 73 to 93 I
was exposed to asbestos in 73 and it was
on my service record all the way up to I
retired in 94 I went to the VA and found
out I had asked best doses well I didn't
have any symptoms so I said well I'll
just wait till I thought have a symptoms
and then all file well I started having
symptoms in 1998 and I went ahead and
went to file then they told me that you
had to file within two years and if you
didn't you were just out of luck so here
I am with the asbestosis and I can't get
a dime from anybody I can't get anybody
the states to do anything so who's
really in charge of this money is this
the government or the big the big
industries controlling the the you know
people like us that are sick and not
being able to get any retribution caller
where what is who is your suit against
and are you part of a class action no I
like I said they know exactly who see I
was tearing down some barracks and on
NES Pensacola so they know it's all my
service record they know exactly who put
the asbestos in there but it doesn't
matter because I did not file within the
two years you in Florida you have to
file within two years of being diagnosed
it doesn't matter if you're showing
signs or not and that's that that's
basic that's it's like a it's a trick to
me because like I said I had no symptoms
whatsoever but now that I do I can't get
any retribution for it thanks call this
is one of the things that's wrong with
the current system although there will
be a similar statute of limitations in
the in the federal legislation if it if
it stays as Senator hatch has drafted it
and what you what you described is is a
plight that is that our predicament that
has hit all too many people the states
have various statute of limitations some
of them go up to six years which you
mentioned in 1992 you were diagnosed and
he started having symptoms in 98 this is
one of the problems and and it's also
sort of an irony about the current
system the courts
are facing or trying to deal with
hundreds of thousands of suits that have
been filed and and the industry says so
many of these suits are filed on behalf
of people who aren't sick well the
problem is once you develop or your
lungs show scarring at the bottom and
where you might have pleural thickening
scarring that causes your your your
flora to thicken but you don't have any
symptoms yet asbestos is a progressive
disease and it takes a while sometimes
it can take up to 40 years before
serious symptoms develop but you have
been diagnosed with an asbestos illness
technically and you are unnoticed to
file a claim against the defendants
companies that you feel put you in a
situation where you were exposed so
you're in a real problem in the courts
have all kinds of cases involving people
who aren't sick yet but have an asbestos
illness technically next call for Greg
Gordon of the Minneapolis star-tribune
on asbestos comes from DeKalb Illinois
Democrat
hello mr. Gordon good morning good
morning
you mentioned Johns Manville but isn't W
our grace the biggest polluter of
asbestos in the country
no john johns manville produced about a
third of the asbestos that was
commercially manufactured in the United
States and distributed W our grace has
had a couple 300,000 claims filed
against it for various products it
produced including fire retardant sprays
which I mentioned before that are you
were used for many years in buildings to
try to contain help contain a fire if it
broke out and it also made the
vermiculite attic insulation that we
have as a current issue now in in
Minnesota and in planned states across
the country where plants used asbestos
contaminated vermiculite vermiculite to
make a variety of products and W our
grace owned many of those plants are
provided the contaminated vermiculite or
too many of those plants next call
Greenwood South Carolina good more
yes sir I was just wondering I remember
when they took all the asbestos out of
the schools and the government spent
billions of dollars removing this
asbestos only to find out later that as
long as it was stationary or undisturbed
it wasn't harmful to anybody I wonder
what else we're gonna find out about
asbestos it I mean how do you determine
who has lung problems from asbestos or
from smoking 3 packs of cigarettes a day
or what where does it end
thank you call you have hit on a point
of contention and in the current
negotiations because smoking and
asbestos have a certain synergy in fact
if you are a smoker and you're also
exposed to asbestos your chances of of
getting lung cancer go up exponentially
in the draft bill that the senator has
proposed a person who smoked and/or
smokes and and suffers from was a lung
cancer will get $50,000 a nine smoker
who has lung cancer and as an asbestos
exposure would get $400,000 the afl-cio
feels that the the number for smokers
who were exposed to asbestos is is way
too low and must come up in and in fact
that that the other number must come up
also but this is the big debate because
the afl-cio has a number that is tens of
billions of dollars higher than 108
billion dollars that is that is
apparently on the table from industry
right now and and the insurance industry
I should add but both both the corporate
in corporations the corporate defendants
and the insurance industry would be
chipping into this big pot next call for
Greg Gordon is will PACA Wisconsin good
morning good morning and thank you for
taking my call I'm a first-time caller
and c-span is very very important to me
my husband has been
oxygen it will be six years in August
and he has asked us ptosis I have been
so offended at the companies that are
filing bankruptcy purely to get out of
covering those people that have been
injured by products that they that they
put out call her where was your husband
exposed to asbestos my husband was in
construction heavy-duty construction for
years and he was exposed at various
places where they had to remove the
asbestos and we know that it was ordered
by the government however that is not
the fault of the client who has the
problem now and I was especially
offended when our vice-president who was
the CEO of that big company who bought a
company that did sell asbestos and he
said that these lawsuits were frivolous
I would like the vice-president to see
what my husband has to go through we
have oxygen 24/7 in our home okay thanks
thanks caller Greg Gordon well what what
you're describing the the emotions that
you're describing the anger is shared by
many many Americans of American workers
and their families is all I can tell you
there are a lot of people very
frustrated right now the idea that they
can only get pennies on the dollar and
there are a lot of there's a lot of
skepticism about some of these
bankruptcies whether companies were
doing doing this essentially to get out
of their responsibilities when when was
it discovered that asbestos could be
damaging the famed researcher Irving
Sela cough at Mount Sinai Hospital in
New York in the early 1960s around 1963
or 1964 was coming out with some very
serious health warnings and here we are
40 years later and we still have new
asbestos exposures occurring in the
United States and in fact there's a
legislation also pending on Capitol Hill
to ban asbestos
something in the range of 30 million
tons came into the indoor produced in
the United States or imported last year
and we who are regular normal people who
aren't involved in in heavy-duty
construction or tearing it out of
schools exposed to asbestos you can you
can be exposed in casual ways Steve
McQueen died of mesothelioma I'm not
sure if anyone knows how he was exposed
we just lost congressman Bruce Vento of
Minnesota in a couple of years ago he
was diagnosed in February of I believe
it was 2001 how would he be in in late
fall that year of mesothelioma he was a
school teacher when he came out got out
of college and in during the summers and
sometimes at nights he worked in various
factories for a few years around the
Twin Cities his his widow has a lawsuit
and family has a lawsuit pending against
the industry Westchester County New York
good morning good morning mr. Gordon
well done on your investigative
reporting by the way thank you very much
it seems that we have a disease
mesothelioma and the only cure apparent
cure are more lawsuits and I'm sure
you'll agree with that there is a
program out there I know as a gentleman
called earlier regarding electromagnets
and stuff like that but there's a very
successful program that was utilized for
drug problems for people that had on a
cellular level particles and toxins in
the body and I know it's been used on
guys coming back from Vietnam with Agent
Orange and also and as early as a few
months ago it's still being very
effective in New York City with the
firemen and it's called a purification
program and this program actually
eliminates toxins and poisons and pulls
it out of the system it's a combination
of sweat program and medically
supervised and the Church of Scientology
is the one that has this program it's
ongoing for years and it's got the
highest non reefs of Italy rate and in
the world when it comes to heroin
addicts not only it handles toxins and
poisons you've probably seen a
commercial on TV about
you know purification it showed like a
volcano exploding and what it does is it
actually handles the toxins and poisons
and pulls it out of this of the tissues
which basically even LSD can remain in
your system for many many years and so
it's something that should be looked at
I think because we're more we're putting
a lot of tension on lawsuits and
creating a disease then really finding a
cure
thank you thank you caller Greg Gordon
well I'm sure that the scientific
community will be very interested in any
approach that will rid these toxins from
people's bodies it's all I can say but
going back to the lawsuit question a lot
of commercials at least here in the DC
area about mesothelioma you see a lot
and call this lawyers number if you have
it are the trial lawyers active in this
the trial lawyers are in a very
interesting position there are a
significant portion probably a small
fraction overall of the tort Bar is
devoted entirely to bringing asbestos
related lawsuits and the lawyers could
be the big losers if such a settlement
is reached and that's really the big
impetus for the for the settlement the
Ran's Institute for civil justice
contends that 61 or 60 percent
I guess it's maybe it's 50 to 59 to 61
percent somewhere in that range of the
overall cost of asbestos litigation over
the last 20-30 years has been for legal
fees both defense and and for the
plaintiffs fees and and this means that
if a victim wins say a million dollars
for mesothelioma a case it might he or
she might end up with six hundred and
sixty seven thousand or six hundred
thousand dollars or maybe even only five
hundred thousand dollars not to say the
lawyers take a lot of risk it's almost
all done on contingency but if this
element is reached
lawyers roles will be diminished
considerably they may be needed to
navigate people through the system but
it won't be it'll be a pretty well
prescribed arrangement Omaha Nebraska
you're on the air with
yeah I want to ask first of all I didn't
hear what sort of live where I've worked
in construction and I wanted to know
what kind of concentration of exposure
it takes to you know potentially develop
asbestos and also in regards to if you
know anything about silica I worked a
lot with ku Stickle tile feelings you
know where there's a potential silica
exposure and in fiberglass insulation
let's get an answer Colorado time you
may not know this but one of the
international agencies recently named
silica dust as a as a carcinogen a
cancer Keizer and how much exposure is
not really known except I think for a
space tells us probably a fair amount
but mesothelioma some some scientists
feel that a casual exposure to to
asbestos can cause mesothelioma in 20 30
40 years later
Gregg gordon is with the Minneapolis
star-tribune an investigative reporter
and also a correspondent here in
Washington if people want to read your
past articles on asbestos where can they
find them Star Tribune calm we'll have a
fair number of them thanks for joining
us my pleasure iris bestest coming up
the house is in session they'll be doing
the Defense Department four hundred
billion dollar appropriation is what
they'll be talking about two hearings
you might be interested in that will be
covering today on c-span includes the
9/11 Commission Lee Hamilton and Tom
Kane were out here earlier to talk about
that they'll be hearing from John McCain
and other senators Jane Garvey former
FAA administrator will be there also the
House Select Committee on Homeland
Security will be hearing from Tom Ridge
today both those hearings will be on
c-span the Tom Ridge homeland security
hearing will be live on c-span 3
beginning just about right now otherwise
check c-span org for scheduling tomorrow
we'll be in New York City
John Bachelor of bachelor and Alexander
WABC radio program will be be one of our
guests will see you tomorrow the house
is now in session